Robert what's your take on the current
state of the film and television
industry right so it's an interesting
thing that has happened recently I mean
the numbers are the the box office in
terms of ticket sales hit a 20-year low
last year in 2014 and at the same time
the sort of cost benefits are enormous
for studios and the finance ears because
it used to be when they made a film it
was a film first of all they shot it on
film had it develop it and produces an
actual film P&A cost prints and
advertising was an enormous cost expense
and that's gone now they don't have to
do it anymore and shipping it around to
2,000 copies of this film to 2000
studios that expense is gone at the same
time the the exhibitors the theaters
there as I said 20-year low and that's
because there are alternatives now wish
there weren't in the past and I think
frankly that's two large degree I think
it's sort of a dying business model the
exhibitors theatres movie theaters
there's certainly something to be said
about going to a theater and sing a
movie and so forth but nowadays for
example I saw Jurassic world last week
and I had to go to the theater at 12 35
and pay for my ticket and there was it
was not crowded but there was some guy
coughing over here and some lady be' and
it was John pleasant and if I had a
choice to see that at home and pay at
least the same amount i would probably
even pay more on my schedule i certainly
would have done so so VOD i think in a
way has certainly crushed the exhibitors
so that's an interesting sort of thing
but i think the the studios are
approaching it in kind of a foolish way
i think about the music industry and
what happened there so Napster came out
right with the music business and Shawn
Fanning said we found this way to
deliver content really simply a music
industry said let's bury this guy this
guy's a threat to us rather than
would have been smart for them to say
let's work with this guy this you know
period there's no theory on Wall Street
that if you have a competitor and there
are a viable threat to you you can try
to crush them and go to war with them or
you can absorb them and by them and it's
much more sensible approach to dealing
with stuff like that and they didn't do
that and at their peril so there was a
lot of damage as a result of that Tower
Records and so forth it's all gone and
they won the battle they shut down
Napster but they lost the war you know
their music business is completely
changed so I think the students need to
sort of embrace that a little bit better
than they're doing now and in terms of
exhibitors you know these big chains and
so forth I just think about it this way
if there's a family of four people that
they want to go see a movie first of all
to schedule it and to hire a babysitter
and to pay for gas and pay for four
separate admission tickets and so forth
if they have a choice to do that versus
see at home on VOD you know that's an
easy decision so I think they need to
sort of it shouldn't be one or the other
kind of thing it should i think really
think all movies should just be VOD I
really do I think it's just you know I
just think or at least an option if you
want to that a theater experience and so
forth I get that seeing san andreas on
the big screen give them the option but
it shouldn't be one or the other in my
view hmm there's a theater near us which
I actually didn't like to go to and now
they've changed it over right now they
have this reclining seats with drink
holders no one kicks your seat behind
you because they're too far right you
can choose your seat ahead of time or
and I'm thinking you know it's actually
worth it for me before I was like for
many years I don't really want to go
there there's all these loud people and
they're kind of rude and stuff now I
actually don't mind going actually it's
an enjoyable experience now I'm not
going to see every film there it's not
worth it to me but don't you think that
there's like you said there's certain
it's a magical sort of ethereal
experience to be in this like silent
theater with a bunch of strangers and
see an emotional scene I do I I think
you're right you know I just I have a
theater near me which is in a small town
and
it was shut down was getting shut down
and these kids sort of reinvigorated it
and they changed the business model a
little bit they refurbish it's all
digital and it's sort of a nice vibe
there it's not this big corporate sort
of you know I definitely think if I
forgive me if I said that that the
theater industry is dead it's not it's
definitely I think it needs to be
changed and I think frankly it's it's
got a its got a it's going to get leaner
and the numbers are going to continue to
decline but they can sort of change
things up and make it a more pleasant
experience definitely and there's
undeniably something important about the
experience of seeing it movie
collectively and that kind of stuff I
just think it should it should not be at
the expense of creating an opportunity
for somebody like me who doesn't want to
go to the theater to see that same day
you know day to day and date kind of VOD
I just think it will supplement them
rather than you know cannibalize them
their business
you